[Music]
what's the origin of his name
um i just heard taiko ytt's name and i'm
like that's a cool name you didn't look
into the origin
oh i did yes there's a lot of meanings
yeah so i googled it and then it meant
something
in like 40 different languages from
norwegian to like
chinese to maori to whatever and i'm
like oh this is really cool and they're
all like pretty positive things
yeah how about um in maori
i think it just means tiger tiger they
got tigers
in new zealand maybe oh was there any
negative thing like one thing that was
negative yeah i couldn't find one okay
this is pretty cool that's good it's an
era in japan is it oh
well speaking of is it mayori or maori
i don't know i've heard it both ways
aorie maui maybe if someone's wrong i
don't know okay
i think it's maori i'll go with maori
what does taika say about can you ask
jason memorial you think he'll know
um he would no he's maori i don't know
i thought he was no he's hawaiian but
i'm just assuming he would know oh yeah
he knows everything that's why she just
wants an excuse to talk to him
true well you brought him up i thought
he was of that culture
see educate him i mean dude you wouldn't
even be able to talk to him
i wouldn't be like aren't you an
atlantean
[Laughter]
i really would not even be able to say a
single word i'll just be like
you just stand and just piss yourself
yeah probably anyway
the article i have here it talks about
how a
canadian brewery and a leather store in
new
new zealand okay so for the brewery they
named one of their beers
after a like they use a miori word
called it's
for one of the beers yes and then as
well as the leather store in new zealand
they all they named their store
leather and beer yes okay and and so
they were thinking that it meant feather
but it actually means pubic hair oh
what if it means both things probably
but uh okay so
this maori tv personality named
te hamua nikora said on facebook
said some people call it appreciation i
call it appropriation
if you are selling leather call it
leather don't call it pubic hair unless
you are selling pubic hair and don't
call beer
pubic hair unless you make it with pubic
hair
so then he asked for non-marry
businesses to use their own language to
promote their products
and they're just pretty much saying like
you look dumb
like why are you using our language what
is the word for leather i don't know
um how do they get it mixed up for
feather like
how did they come to the conclusion
because both companies thought it meant
feathers so there's got to be a source
citing this and they maybe it's like
hula hulu and then they wrote
so in terms of the the brewery it's
called the brewery's called
hell's basement and they called it's new
zealand
pale ale beer right so then
pubic hair yeah
but they meant it obviously in a you
know like this is like uh
it's like when guys get like the chinese
tattoos and right in their heads this is
like cool
this is like dick yeah pubic hair people
get tribal tattoos all the time too you
know it's like of like of
all different tribes and and cultures
yeah what does it mean
because you have a chinese tattoo and it
means something else right this
no he does oh you do he got a japanese
tattoo
and it means something else sit up in my
head yeah right what does it mean
so you know how he found out my mom
called him out on it that's what he
wants because i thought it was his mom
calling you out so i mixed it up in my
head
so what did you think it meant and then
what did you find out of me
this is my best friend at the time uh we
just graduated boot camp
and we were in north carolina and we
wanted to get something that was kind of
like tough you know
yeah so we google translated i fear no
one and i'm like what's a tough
asian language like japanese samurai
there's like samurai spirit
and then so it's supposed to say fear no
one but i think it really says
fear everywhere because my mom was like
it says the opposite
yeah because my mom read it and she's
like
who's your friend scared of
literally everybody that's good that is
sick dude
that's kind of cool that's wrong
don't trust google translate for your
tattoo inspiration no
never i like that you just did it on
your phone like yeah it's done
put it on my body yeah that's so ballsy
because that's a white bro
dude i know and there was a random like
white guy at a tattoo shop he was like
are you sure this is right because even
he was like i went to japan for five
years i don't think that's right
he was like fear everyone
like he's a marine he has some
experiences
he does more than i do damn he could
actually read
it
[Laughter]
that's so funny yeah yeah so the brewery
they said
we did not realize the potential to
offend through our artistic
interpretation and given the response we
will attempt to do better
in the future to those who feel
disrespected we apologize we do not
think
pubic hair is shameful though we admit
it may not go well with beer
so at least that's what the brewery said
so they're going to change the name yeah
they're going to change it and then so
the leather store
kuru said that they meant no offense by
using the name
for their store and that they also
intended it to mean
like wool feather or fur and
that's why they intended for it to mean
scrotum
oh yeah what's this chair oh yeah it's
scrotum man that's nice right
so wait is this is the leather store
changing the name as well i mean because
that's their
brand that's at this point they kind of
gotta keep it i know right
yeah i feel for all the companies that
need to change their entire identity
like like all the bands too with like
like
yeah lady a yeah they should after like
learning what it is
like change it again one more time oh
lady a with the artist yeah
the artist too they went and i ran to
another issue now with some other
uh and she's a black singer i think so
yeah like she's suing them for taking
over
the name lady a now because her name
he's been using it forever
oh yeah but the band was doing her right
like
for defamation it was like the band yeah
the band
and everyone was like what the hell are
you doing
wow because the band was like well we
trademarked this before
you been using it but she's like but
i've been using it forever right
right yeah it's tricky but yeah like for
like that for
like um like some kind of vietnamese
restaurant
or like it was like a a word that
shouldn't be trademarked
because it was like a dish like it was
pokey or whatever no
i think it was poke it wasn't vietnamese
so then you know how like pokey is
everywhere right and then i think a
restaurant they
took pokey trademarked it they started
suing all the pokey restaurants
that's crazy yeah that's like
trademarking hamburger and just
laughter like i should have never passed
the trademarking lot like yeah
sure yeah that's true that is
interesting that it even passed
i think it was when pokey first started
and no one knew what it was no i know
what it was
damn that's like [ __ ] pinkberry dude
pinkberry started i was like what the
[ __ ] is this but then it's like
yogurtland everything else
it's just all sprouted yeah at the same
time out of nowhere that's what it felt
like
and then now they're gone gone i miss
pinkberry paintberry was delicious it
was good i like it better than
yogurtlands
yogurt i'm gonna have to fight you on
that really with all the flavors yeah i
liked all the different you guys
remember red mango too
yeah do you remember red mango when you
could make your own
yeah oh i thought red mango was a flavor
because i'd never heard of it red meat
so i the star that i heard was pink
berry
uh so red mango existed in korea first
and then pink berry they're like oh cool
i'll bring that to america
so they came to america first they blew
up and i think red mango was like
[ __ ] you guys you guys stole my idea and
they came and started battling out but
then
yogurtland came out with their business
model where you could just customize
your own just do your own and they just
kind of while they were kind of
bickering they both died didn't
yogurtland or pinkberry ceo beat up a
homeless dude with a bat
or something i've been a fan ever since
yeah and then i think
maybe that probably shut them down it's
so funny
these dessert wars right cause it's like
it's like
it's such a cute dessert but anytime you
add like korean businessman to the mix
it's kind of gangster
if it comes down don't have these crazy
arguments so it's like
it's such a cute dessert and you have
the most
gangsterous dudes like running it it's
so funny
the dudes behind hello kitty are just
notorious for the scary people
i've heard the japanese yakuza is behind
it right
you just never know damn all right so
back to the story so
the uh the leather store
right saying that they had gotten
approval
approval for that name from the
intellectual property office's maori
advisory committee
and so they were like i thought it was
cool
yeah that committee was like yeah take
the name
i know right they're like you want to
name it puberty care they're like
all right [ __ ] preparation you're
gonna pay us for that
word all right sounds sick guys
sounds good yeah it'll be good yeah fear
everyone sure
can you change that can you get like
never on top of it or something i mean i
could change it but then it just became
such a funny thing
and it's also in the world there's only
two people that have it and they're not
even friends
i'm never gonna i'm never gonna go best
friend matching tattoos that aren't
friends anymore
it's just too good i like it i like it
and there's a story behind it
it's like you gotta yeah wow this is too
good i would never cover it there ever a
success story for
matching tattoos because every time i
hear about anyone getting matching
tattoos with anyone like they no longer
speak or anything it's like maybe it's a
curse would you remove it if the other
person removed it too
no because i'm then on the only lasting
like encyclopedia of this stupid story
it's so fun it's so funny because nobody
gets not tough things on on their body
yeah right like everyone gets the
toughest words like i'm scared
i'm scared nobody gets that everyone
gets the toughest words the sickest
looking dragons
like they don't do that i think i should
do that
i said i should get tattoos or like have
a whole store
that's like words of different countries
or or or cultures
but they're like the lamest ones you
have the lamest animals yeah they're
gonna be very successful or maybe very
successful
true oh there you go do you have any
tattoos i i i have my wife's name and my
daughter's name just like yeah just like
you know
cool very like ruby that's my daughter
yeah my wife's name
yeah yeah sweet they didn't have that
thing on the door we did but i don't
think that guy speaks english oh he
didn't read
he's all trying to like force himself in
yeah he was going to break the door down
jeez i know i think that would have been
funny to just keep it in here
yeah oh what the
well there's like a good minute that's
an aloha right there oh so then you have
those two tattoos yeah
um have you ever considered doing a
tattoo language
no no and i recommend google translate
go wrong it might be better now than
before it's probably way better now
oh man i don't know i don't trust it
because sometimes i forget my spanish
and then i go into google translate and
see like oh is this how you say it and
then
it translates it really weird so i'm
like that's not how you say it either i
think that the i've had it
has the thing that's hard for it is um
you know how like
i think it's the grammar part you know
some languages you have the order matter
so like it would be like i love you in
some languages but then some languages i
you love
all right yeah that's wrong that's what
happened with this where i typed in fear
no one when it's and so i guess it goes
like uh
like i don't know how it turned into
fear everywhere but it had something to
do with the order of it yeah
the characters yeah also the meanings of
words sometimes
change you know over time and if it
changes into like a thing that you don't
want
later you know like you know true like
if if if like your name's karen
oh you're going and you put karen across
your forehead
like karen not quite the same anymore or
even
the idea of fear no one like has that
state consistent i think you fear karen
yeah i am really scared of cancer i'm
scared of caring
like [ __ ] sake
[Music]
you